I'm gonna treat you better than Sony did
and let you know right now there are
spoilers for endgame so the trailer the
new trailer for spider-man far from home
I'm actually really annoyed at this
thing not for the fact that it has
endgame traits the eye spoilers I've
already seen endgame but I wasn't going
to see this trailer I was actively
planning to not watch it because I
already knew I was gonna see this movie
I saw the first trailer I gave my
thoughts on the first trailer and I
already know I'm gonna see this and when
that happens I try to not fall into the
trap of watching in four trailer that
comes out because since I know I'm going
anyway any trailer I get that gives me
any degree of new information risks
spoiling me whether it is with an
outright spoiler or just giving me
enough information that my brain starts
making connections and guessing what's
gonna happen and I don't want that so I
was not gonna see this trailer except
that the thing that's the big spoiler
thing that while not the big end games
for the thing but the main thing that
like I would not have wanted spoiled for
me like everyone started talking about
it and like to the point that it and
it's the kind of thing that they put it
in like the headlines of articles and
like the names of videos and while I can
avoid reading an article looking at a
video it's really hard for me to avoid
looking at the names of them so even
though I was able to avoid any game
spoilers for a week until I got to the
movie I couldn't avoid this crap so this
is your last warning let's talk about
the possibility of there being a
multiverse in the MCU mostly there's
gonna be be me saying why that's
absolutely not what's going on here I'm
gonna start with my big massive piece of
evidence for that and then it'll
honestly be a lack of evidence but just
me explaining why it's a stupid idea and
I'm just kind of operating on the
presumption that Marvel is smarter
then then doing this cuz it's dumb so
first of all I'll acknowledge I'm not a
huge Multi fan of multiverse stories I
don't hate them automatically I just for
the few times that I've seen good stuff
come out of a multiverse story I've seen
way more stuff that I just have
absolutely no interest is and I think is
stupid or contrived or what-have-you
so I'm not inherently partial to even
seeing a multiverse get introduced
really anywhere so let's start with the
big massive clear obvious reason why
there isn't gonna be a multiverse
despite the fact that this trailer seems
to indicate that there is who is the
main provider of the information that
indicates there's a multiverse I know
it's Nick Fury's line but who's he
referring to Mysterio
what is Mysterio's entire deal it's
tricking people it is fooling people it
is being a con man that's what he is and
it would be very simple for an
opportunistic bastard which Quentin Beck
is to you know see the results of the
snap and go man that mess was so much I
bet that if I construct this carefully
enough and use the right effects and
whatnot that I can convince people that
I'm from another dimension
because what wouldn't they believe these
days that's totally what's going on here
there is no way he's actually from the
multiverse because again that is
Mysterio's entire freaking deal so I'm
now just gonna ramble on why it would be
very stupid if it was a more if it was a
multiverse then again this is me just
presuming that Kevin Feige and the other
folks over handling BMC you all know
what I'm about to talk about so here's
the thing you can't just sight at me all
the reasons that multiverses or that
some people claim multiverses work in
the comics because the nature of the
comics and the sprawl
nature of the comics where not only are
there a bajillion characters but there's
a bajillion variants on the characters
does allow you to dabble in this stuff a
bit more than I think you can ever
reasonably expect to get away with in
movies I do know that that kind of
argument doesn't hold the kind of weight
that it used to it used to be said you
couldn't put superheroes in comic
accurate costumes you couldn't get away
with that on film and for the most part
we've now been proven wrong on that so I
and Yost people would have said this
thing about inter continuity at a point
but this isn't in my mind this isn't
that issue of confusing the audience
which is the patronizing way to you know
make an argument about that
no I think people can wrap their head
around it it is asking a lot more work
and it's not I don't think it's an issue
that audiences can't wrap their heads
around it they may not feel it's worth
the effort that's a slightly different
argument but the thing is that the way
that fandom is in general especially you
know with how prevalent you know fan
theories are and how quickly this this
stuff spreads Marvel has a pretty good
handle on how that entire thing works
now I do understand that this movie is
being released by Sony but the
spider-man field films are being
shepherded by Marvel and Nick Fury's
appearing in this that would have had to
have been signed off on by Marvel the
same as Iron Man in the previous one so
there's no way that Sony could could
inject something like multiverse on
their own authority Marvel would have
had to have signed off on this we Marvel
understanding the way that fans tend to
be they would know that if they hint
much less confirm that there's a
multiverse ie alternate dimensions ie
alternate variants of these characters
that we know and this world that we've
already come to expect that means that
there is going to be nonstop calling all
the time of oh well we can get Iron Man
back and we can get Captain
come back and we can get all these
characters back because we can get the
alternate dimension versions of them and
look these characters are coming back
iron man's done Captain America's done
Chris Evans of Robert Downey jr. are
done playing these parts and if there
varies if Marvel is very smart they will
not have them back not even for cameos
not even for joke one-off things and not
indefinitely not for alternate-dimension
versions because the instant you do that
you start getting a bunch of people
screaming at you why aren't you bringing
them back because their stories are done
and this is what this is an area where
the movies have to diverge from the
comics because in the comics the stories
never end story arcs and but the story
of these characters never end and they
just keep going forever you can't do
that with film because the actors get
old and want to do other stuff it's not
like when your artist gets tired you
just hire another artist and they've had
these actors playing these characters
for so long that I don't think recasting
is really in the cards that's why they
had Tony Stark died that's why they had
cap aged to the point where now he very
obviously can't be Captain America
anymore they're closing the book on
these characters and not to mention the
fact all the other stuff that people are
gonna start asking for if you do a
multiverse you're gonna start people
saying oh can we get the Hugh Jackman
Wolverine can we get the Tobey Maguire
version of spider-man can we get that
can we get no dick and this is my big
issue with multiverse things the fun you
get out of the few times that it gets
done well in my mind really gets
undermined and kind of it completely
counterbalanced by the fact that well
now you now that you can do virtually
anything you're kind of expected to and
if you don't people are wondering why
aren't you and because I know somebody
will bring it up somebody's probably
guys
what about into the spider-verse didn't
that work didn't that make multiverse
work well yes in a completely
self-contained story in
a different medium because I do consider
to be animation to be a different medium
from live-action not only because of the
process of what's involved in making it
but also in terms of at least in America
the way that audiences take it in as a
piece of entertainment so let me put it
this way if the sequel to spider-verse
or anything so set in that world ever
brought in versions of spider-man voiced
by Tobey Maguire Andrew Garfield and or
Tom Holland I wouldn't actually take as
much of an issue with that because I
don't believe that audiences mmm
they don't overlap animation and
live-action in their minds especially
not if the originating thing is
live-action like I think most people
would take that in the spirit it would
be intended which is oh that's a neat
fun thing and not necessarily be
expecting follow up now if they had a
version of Miles Morales you know
presumably live-action who's very
clearly from the version we saw from
spider-verse ever show up in a live
action movie and imply that he is from
another dimension that I'm gonna have a
problem with this is the same reason
that I've already mentioned stuff but
it's because that's establishing it into
live-action I think the jump from
meeting from animation to live-action
gives its into the spider verse a bit
more wiggle room and also I'll admit to
the fact that spider verse on paper
should not have worked but it did but
that to me is not a proof of concept
that multiverse will work as a story
point it to me it says Wow
even a bad idea can be done right once
that does not mean anybody should be
doing again they hit the lottery other
people should not be going well there's
my retirement plan I'll buy a lottery
ticket like don't and I and you know
what to a certain extent I will come to
the idea that you multiverses are
confusing not if you actually dig in to
follow them but like on at a glance they
are confusing so look basically
everybody ever has seen endgame and or
will it
insane how much money this movie is made
in the amount of time that's made it so
pretty much everybody wrap it is
wrapping their head around and is aware
of Tony dize cap is done Natasha dies
and if you then do the trailer where is
like oh I'm from another dimension
you're gonna get a lot of people going
wait what and that's not to say that
they can't understand it if they
actually sat down to watch the movie but
in trying to sell the movie to them
you're gonna get like wait but huh and
that was that's honestly what turned me
off when I was young too the idea of the
DC Multiverse it wasn't the actual
stories I just didn't even bother to
read them in the first place because
someone tried to explain to me well no
but there's this version of Superman
from another earth who actually you know
is now a bit older and I'm like what
stop I don't care just why and now how
do I actually read them I might well
have liked them but it made me
uninterested even before then and it's
completely needless complication like I
don't think that like in Marvel doesn't
really do multiverse but III know
technically they have on multiverse but
they don't really do multiverse driven
stories like they had the ultimate
universe I guess the 2099 universe is
also technically a different universe
and you know they've had their little
weird oddities here and there but the
actual crossing over between the the
different universes is not really
marvelous thing that's much more DC's
thing and actually I would argue that DC
has kind of done it better for the most
part usually there's big exceptions to
that I though I don't want to stand by
that too strongly but look I don't think
you we get good stories out of
multiverses I just don't and I just
think it needs and and yeah I don't
think it is I really don't think it is
because again it's the Serio it's not a
multiverse so the trailer do you have
any thoughts on the trailer besides this
nonsense that I just spent however long
rambling about whatever your thoughts
are job
something down the comments let's talk
about it punches up to do buttons links
patreon much appreciated um plus a bunch
of other stuff click on the link see
where they take you or don't you don't
have to because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]